thanks to squarespace for helping
support this episode
hey crazies life as we know it requires
liquid water and that's only possible on
the surface of a planet if that planet
is in the habitable zone of its system
earth is right in the middle of ours but
at the inner edge you'll find venus and
at the outer edge you'll find mars
of course neither of them is habitable
for the same reason their atmospheres
venus's thick atmosphere retains too
much heat mars's thin atmosphere doesn't
retain enough
but what if in some alternate universe
venus formed in mars orbit would it be
habitable then
[Music]
this episode was made possible by the
generous support of our patrons and
youtube members
i think it'll be best if we start with
what venus is like now
it's about the same size as earth so it
can hold on to more atmosphere than mars
and boy does it ever
venus atmosphere is mostly carbon
dioxide or co2 and it's super thick
the pressure is 92 times what we have on
earth
yeah you heard that right 92 times
venus will crush you like a pancake
it's really hot on the surface too but
not because it's closer to the sun
almost no light reaches the surface
that super thick atmosphere and these
shiny clouds reflect a bunch of it back
into space
the reason it's so hot on the surface is
because the co2 in the atmosphere
absorbs infrared light holding in the
heat
the surface temperature is a steady
fahrenheit
that's 470 celsius
even crazier venus atmosphere is so
dense that it doesn't even matter if
it's day or night
it's 870 fahrenheit all the time imagine
being covered with thousands of blankets
you'd get crushed and you'd burn up from
your own body heat
if somehow you survived that you'd still
have to deal with the rain
these clouds aren't made of water like
earth clouds they're sulfuric acid
it literally rains sulfuric acid on
venus
is that an actual picture oh yeah it is
does that mean we landed there yeah it
does
these pictures were taken by one of the
soviet venera probes during the 1970s
the russians built a venus lander and it
lasted almost an hour
humans rock
anyway
venus got that way because it's a
runaway greenhouse actually venus is not
in a runaway greenhouse effect
what the term runaway greenhouse effect
it's kind of reserved for something
different than just a very strong
greenhouse effect really wait who are
you chris close dr chris kolhaus from
the nasa goddard institute for space
studies yeah cool uh what exactly do you
do there it's primarily an earth climate
modeling center but there's a few people
that have done modeling of planetary
atmospheres and exoplanet interests and
such i'm part of that exoplanet modeling
group
ah so this is definitely in your
wheelhouse okay so if venus isn't a
runaway greenhouse then what is it
it's fair to call it strong or
supercharged or whatever but it's it's
reached in equilibrium it's it's right
right it's an equilibrium and it's just
it's just a very hot equilibrium so
what's a runaway greenhouse it actually
refers to a very specific process in
which the outgoing radiation cannot
reach the absorbed solar radiation oh
so venus had a runaway greenhouse in the
past but has since stopped
what is thought to maybe have occurred
on early venus
okay so i just learned so much that my
brain hurts but i'm gonna try to
summarize
say you've got some random planet it
doesn't matter which one
its average surface temperature can be
determined by a relatively simple
equation
incoming light from the sun minus
outgoing light from the planet which is
mostly infrared
that's it
the trick is knowing what happens with
those numbers under different
circumstances and that's what we're
going to need to know if we plan on
moving venus around
naturally there will be less incoming
light if the planet is further from the
sun
light leaving a source gets spread out
over a larger and larger area as it
moves away
it's called an inverse square law
because the intensity drops with the
square of the distance
we measure area in square units square
miles square feet square meters you get
the idea
mars's orbit is a little over twice as
far from the sun as venus if venus
formed there instead it would receive
less than a quarter of the light which
is pretty significant
does that mean it would be one quarter
of the temperature actually no
if you put an ice cube on the counter
it'll seek an equilibrium with its
warmer surroundings
for this ice cube that means it'll
eventually melt but that ice cube is in
contact with a counter and surrounded by
air
a planet like venus is floating in the
vacuum of space it's not in contact with
anything
except the light from the sun
the intensity of that light is not
proportional to temperature though
it's proportional to the fourth power of
temperature something we call the stefan
boltzmann law
if we want to think of venus as being
enveloped in light we're gonna need to
factor that in
by the time the light gets to this
alternate venus
the intensity would be less than a
quarter of what it is for our venus
but the effective temperature of that
light would be the fourth root of that
or about 69
so not as cold as you might think
however
the amount of light that arrives at a
planet is not necessarily the amount
that arrives at the surface remember
when i said this
that super thick atmosphere and these
shiny clouds reflect a bunch of it back
into space
venus is the most reflective of any of
the eight planets
very little light actually reaches the
surface from space
it's not pitch black but it is dark
think just after dusk on a cloudy day
what venus's atmosphere does with the
outgoing infrared light is what keeps it
so hot
since planets like venus are surrounded
by empty space the only way they can
exchange heat with that space is through
light
while the incoming light from the sun
tries to warm the planet up the planet
also tries to cool off by emitting light
mostly in the infrared range but you
know how we have these things called
greenhouses
they're really useful for growing plants
because they let light in but don't let
the hot air out it's a temperature
regulation system
planets do a similar thing to retain
heat it's called the greenhouse effect
but the mechanism is a little different
than an actual greenhouse
for one if a greenhouse gets too hot
they just open a vent you can't do that
on a planet
also planets aren't surrounded by glass
but they are surrounded by gas
i'm such a dork
some of those gases absorb infrared
light and send it back to the surface
they're called greenhouse gases
because they help the planet hold in
heat kind of like a greenhouse
any planet will find a balance between
incoming and outgoing light eventually
remember the simple equation incoming
light minus outgoing light when those
two factors are balanced the planet is
said to be in equilibrium it's not
heating up or cooling down
uncontrollably
a weak greenhouse lets more infrared
light leak into space that'll give you a
cold desert like we find on mars
with a strong greenhouse there's less
infrared light leaking into space
that'll give you something like the
hellscape we see on venus
now we don't actually know that much
about venus's past resurfacing events
have kind of wiped the slate clean
but this equation does tell us a little
bit
it tells us that at some point in
venus's past it was receiving far more
light than it could emit
venus could have easily started with a
large shallow ocean the increasing heat
on the surface just evaporated it
but what if we caught that before it
even began
if we were to move venus to mars orbit
now nothing would change
the damage has already been done it's a
hellscape and likely will be for a very
long time
but if in some alternate universe venus
just formed there instead of mars it
actually stands a chance it's more
massive than mars so its higher gravity
would help it hold on to more atmosphere
which includes more human-friendly gases
like oxygen and nitrogen
by the inverse square law venus would
receive less light in its new orbit
less than a quarter of the light which
means about 69 of the incoming heat
but doesn't it still have the carbon
dioxide yes but not as much of it in its
younger days
the habitable zone around a star is
defined by the limits of the greenhouse
effect
for various reasons there are limits to
how warm greenhouse gases can keep a
planet's surface
beyond this point they just suck at it
at least the heavier ones that rocky
planets like venus can hold onto
if venus formed out there it could have
found equilibrium before the climate got
carried away it could have been earth
2.0
just kept warm with a little less light
and a little more
co2 mind you this is all a bit
speculative
as dr colas mentioned in our
conversation plate tectonics is sort of
a
complex variable in this story
geologic activity in the distant past
can have wild effects on the present
the point is we don't know if venus
would have been habitable in this
alternate universe
but it would definitely have less
incoming light and more outgoing light
which would have at least made it
possible for venus to be habitable and
if you ask me that's pretty cool
so would you move to venus if it formed
in mars orbit let us know in the
comments
if you want to listen to the entire
conversation with dr chris kolos i
posted it to the second channel huge
thanks to chris for taking the time to
talk to me thanks for liking and sharing
this video don't forget to subscribe if
you'd like to keep up with us and until
next time remember it's okay to be a
little crazy
this episode was sponsored by
squarespace the all-in-one platform to
build a beautiful online presence and
run your business
there are lots of reasons you might want
a website if you don't have a coding
background or good design instincts
though you're gonna have a rough time
with squarespace
making a website is easy and quick they
have tons of design templates that look
professional on all devices
do you need your website to accept
payments squarespace has a template for
that
do you need it to be shareable on social
media they have a template for that too
go to squarespace.com for a free trial
and when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com science asylum and add
code science asylum at checkout to save
10 off your first purchase
so yahtzee next
that would be so much harder because you
count all your rolls together for one
score
stats clone might revolt
besides it seems as though people aren't
interested in game analysis
anyway thanks for watching